hello believe nation it's evan my one
word is believe and i believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope
is that if you believe in yourself as
much as i believe in you you'll be able
to change the planet
so to help you on your journey today i'm
doing a video on the 10 skills that are
hard to learn
but will pay off forever and as always
guys as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
leave it down the comments below it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
and if you leave a comment within the
first few hours of the video going live
you have a chance to win one of two
daily prizes enjoy
skill number one is speaking up
one of the things you would want to be
sure to do
uh is whether you like it or not
get very comfortable it may take a while
with public speaking for example i mean
that
that's a an asset that will last you 50
or 60 years and it's a liability
if you don't like doing it or
uncomfortable doing it that also
will last you 50 or 60 years and it's a
necessary skill
skill number two is being honest with
yourself
one of the big things that all startups
do is they lie to themselves
over and over and over mine's faster
mine's cheaper
mine's better mine's this mine's that
no it's not and the reason it's not is
because whoever it is you're competing
with
it's not like they're ignoring you it's
not like oh my goodness
this guy just started on shopify in the
startup competition he's doing a million
dollars this year
woe is me i might as well close up the
doors what are they doing i'm gonna copy
what they're doing and now you've got to
stay ahead
and so you know you've got to be very
careful as an entrepreneur to be
brutally honest with yourself
um and those are some of the things that
you'll hear from me as a mentor
that you know know what you know know
what you don't know but you've got to
know your business better than anybody
skill number three is having confidence
i don't know if you'd agree with me on
this but in many ways one of the key
factors to legendary success
isn't your natural ability it's not
whether you have the right product it's
not whether you're in the right
field it's not whether you've had a
blessed background
it's not whether you have the right iq
i want you to really think about and
deconstruct
and play with maybe later tonight in
your journal
i want you to deconstruct this idea of
confidence
and it seems like a very simple word but
just think about it in your own life
when you have confidence or we could
even call it fire
when you have that fire within you that
confidence that
interior bravery
you almost have this power to do
whatever it takes to get
your brave vision done you see
in this world it's not about you know in
many ways your strategy in your business
or your ability in your life it's about
this thing called
confidence and we've all had these times
in our lives when we are
full of confidence and what other people
see is a problem we simply do see as an
opportunity
other people see it as a stumbling block
block or a wall and we see it as a
stepping stone
or this solution and so confidence is
something that you really want to wire
in confidence is something you really
want to develop
confidence is a practice confidence is a
muscle
and like any muscle the more you focus
on it
and practice it and train it the
stronger
your confidence is going to grow and i
just have to say it again
when you are at a place in your life
when there is an
ongoing steady state stream of
confidence moving through your mindset
moving through your heart set you do the
heroic in your business
and you achieve the remarkable in your
life skill number four
is listening nelson mandela is
a particularly special case study in the
leadership world
because he is universally regarded as a
great leader
you can take other personalities and
depending on the nation you go to we
have different opinions about other
personalities but nelson mandela
across the world is universally regarded
as a great leader
he was actually the son of a tribal
chief
and he was asked one day how did you
learn to be a great leader
and he responded that he would go with
his father
to tribal meetings and he remembers two
things
when his father would meet with other
elders one
they would always sit in a circle
and two his father was always
the last to speak you will be told your
whole life that you need to learn to
listen
i would say that you need to learn to be
the last to speak
i see it in boardrooms every day of the
week even people who consider themselves
good leaders who may actually be
decent leaders will walk into a room and
say here's the problem here's what i
think but i'm interested in your opinion
let's go around the room
it's too late the skill to hold your
opinions to yourself until everyone has
spoken
does two things one it gives everybody
else the feeling
that they have been heard it gives
everyone else the ability to feel
that they have contributed and two
you get the benefit of hearing what
everybody else has to think before you
render your opinion
the skill is really to keep your
opinions to yourself
if you agree with somebody don't nod yes
if you disagree with somebody don't not
know
simply sit there take it all in and the
only thing you're allowed to do is
ask questions so that you can understand
what they mean
and why they have the opinion that they
have you must understand
from where they are speaking why they
have the opinion they have
not just what they are saying and at the
end
you will get your turn it sounds easy
it's not practice being the last to
speak
that's what nelson mandela did skill
number five
is managing your time my
challenge in our generation is it
gradually through entertainment through
television through media through every
way possible we are living in a
generation of the dumbing
down of ideas because
we have traded effectiveness
for busyness statistics say
yeah somebody ought to clap on that
we are busier than any other generation
we have seen in the last three to four
hundred years
we are so busy we are we are busier than
a wall within a one-armed wallpaper
hangar we're just busy
you'll get it later don't worry about it
it'll hit you in a minute we are just
as busy as we can be and we think
because we're busy
we're effective but i want you to
challenge your schedule for a minute
and ask yourself are you are you really
being effective
or is your life cluttered with all kinds
of stuff that demands you and drains you
and taxes you and stops you from being
your highest
and best self and are you substituting
busyness and all the chaos that goes
along with business
from being effective let me tell you a
bunch of scientists got together they
begin to do some research
and they begin to determine that 80 of
the things
we do are busy things that we do in an
area that is not effective that the
average person only
spends 20 percent of their time
doing the thing that they are really
gifted at created at
passionate about excited to do and the
rest of it
is all the dismal dumb stuff that we all
have to do in order
to survive just crazy stuff that we're
doing wonder what would happen
if we would go from doing 80 of things
that are busy but not effective
and 20 of the things that are really
effective if we would
switch those numbers around and only
give 20 percent of our time to the
things that we have to do
and 80 of our time to the thing that we
were created to do
wonder what would happen to your life
now think about it a minute i
there's a lot of things you could take
from me and i could make it you could
take my suit
i got another one you could take my car
i could get another one
you could take my house i could get
another house
but when you take my time
you have taken something from me that is
totally
irreplaceable we take all kind of
classes for money management
we we know how to manage our money we
know how to repair our houses
we're working on our hair and our bodies
and all of this kind of stuff
we do everything except the most
important thing is to
value our time it
takes time to be creative
you were meant to be creative you were
created in the likeness and the image of
a creator
and in that likeness and in that image
you have
creativity if you had time
you would be creative but in the absence
of time
and with busyness and clutter and people
the following baby
y'all got music playing on your phone
all kinds of stuff and no matter what
kind of song you put on
after a while you hate to hear it
because every time you hear that sound
you know it
somebody else wants something else from
you
that's taking you away from what you are
gifted
and creative to do skill number six is
stop
whining so i have this thing that i've
been promoting called no whining
wednesdays
wednesday you cannot whine complain
or criticize and people like well what
is whining
whatever you think it is don't do it
every time you do it you have to put a
quarter in a jar
if you whine about anything i can't i'm
tired
of me why don't you what happened
every one of them will cost you a
quarter or complaining
why don't you why do you always how come
you i always
they never cost you a quarter
then last week i had people send me
pictures of their jaws or quarters
oh my god but what they said to me
also was this was wonderful because i
was
never ever aware of how much whining
and complaining and criticizing i do
now i've got mothers doing it with their
children
so wednesday is no whining wednesday
we need to practice that we need to stop
whining about what isn't happening what
we don't have what we can't do
what somebody didn't do we got to get it
clean in 2014
no whining no complaining
no criticizing skill number seven
is staying present in the moment if
you're living in the past you're going
to be depressed because
you are rehashing things that happen to
you that are not going to happen again
if you're living in the future you're
going to be anxious because you are
anticipating what's coming or you're
wishing for things that aren't happening
yet
being in the present is where the gold
is being in the present moment
is where you will have the greatest
control
where you will feel the most at ease and
where
happiness flourishes there's a super
tight connection between happiness and
the ability to live in the present
moment
a lot of people believe that happiness
is tied to the things that happened to
you
not so at all in fact there is a
professor of positive psychology he's
one of the grandfathers of
the movement he teaches at the
university of pennsylvania his name is
martin segelman and he studied happiness
for decades
now one of the things that we've talked
about a lot is that 40
of your happiness levels are preset by
genetics
60 you are in complete control of
and one of the things that this
professor has has
discovered is that it doesn't matter
what's happened to you in fact some of
the people
that have had the worst things the worst
things happened to them like people that
have survived the holocaust
are actually the happiest and most
grateful people in the world
happiness comes down to this right up
here
comes down to your thoughts comes down
to your mindset it comes down to your
attitude
and you are 100 control
of what you're thinking you may not be
in control of how you feel in the moment
but you can
always always always always be in
control of what you think
and that will change how you're feeling
one of the most powerful things that you
can do in terms of think and this gets
back to strict's question is
how do you be present being present is
literally
nothing more than the skill of having
your thoughts be in this moment not in
the past
not in the future but right here the way
that you teach yourself how to do that
is that the moment that you catch
yourself
being distracted the moment you catch
yourself starting to worry
the moment you catch yourself drifting
to the future drifting to the past
that's a moment of tremendous power
because you basically just woke up
you basically just noticed that you're
not here in this particular moment
so use that wake up call 54321 and
ground yourself in this moment
the best way to ground yourself in the
moment is to look for something
in this particular moment that you can
savor now i'm using the word saver
on purpose because it's the word that
psychologists use to describe
what happens when you find something in
this moment
right now right here right now to focus
on
and to appreciate it could be literally
the questions these are these are
printed out questions from people on
social media and
if i were to stop and look at these and
savor them
what i would feel in this moment is a
tremendous amount of gratitude because
people are taking the time to write
and that makes me feel incredibly
grateful and it also makes me very happy
because it means that
that the folks that are writing are
taking control of their lives and
seeking out the information that they
need
another form of savoring that we can all
relate to is eating
as you're eating instead of drifting to
the future and thinking about all the
things that you need to do
or hanging out in the past and rehashing
everything that's happened during the
day
be in this moment in this meal slow down
think about the food that you're eating
think about the people that you're
sitting with
and how you feel about them and if you
want to take it up a notch
actually acknowledge them hey this food
tastes amazing thank you for cooking or
i'm so glad to see you and that we get
the time to have this meal together
those small simple acts of savoring are
how you
expand your happiness inside the present
moment
so how do you be more present simple
the moment that you catch yourself in
the future in the past worrying whatever
refocus yourself right here right now
and then find something
right here right now that you can savor
and when you do that
you're not only going to be present
you're going to feel more grateful and
you're gonna feel a little boost of
happiness
skill number eight being consistent
success is not um it's success not a
destination people always think that oh
my god this person's so successful
because they've had a successful movie
or a successful show but success is a
journey
you have to consistently always always
be successful that's when you're really
successful because otherwise you'll be
remembered for your last failure and
i've had a few
but i just have to compensate for um
my failure by just getting up and
running the more time
you take to sort of mourn it you're
wasting that much more time in being
successful
so you just have to you know perk up
pick yourself up dust yourself off and
just say all right
what can i do there's always a solution
you can't expect
people always get mistaken that just
because because this year has been what
it has been
it's been because i consistently worked
hard for about 10 years
so now i know my job enough to be able
to be appreciated for it
but if i hadn't had the last 10 years i
would never have had
this year or the year before that so
success is not a destination where you
or power is not like okay today you're
powerful you have to consistently
be powerful and consistently be
successful and that
is a journey skill number nine is
getting enough
sleep well first of all i prioritize
sleep
and that means making that means saying
no to things you want to do it's not
easy
it is hard i think the hardest thing
yeah last night um
you know cheryl sandberg interviewed me
at the san francisco symphony hall
and then i had to sign books and i would
have loved to
go and have dinner with her but i went
to bed
and you know because if i hadn't got if
i had gone out to dinner
and hadn't gotten my at least seven
hours sleep that i need and had to get
up early to do tv
i would not be enjoying being here with
you now and i'm really enjoying it and
100
present i'm not tired and i hate being
tired more than i hate anything
and skill number 10 is having empathy
i've thought a lot about the power of
empathy in my work it's the current
that connects me and my actual pulse
to a fictional character in a made-up
story it allows me to feel
pretend feelings and sorrows and
imagined
pain and my
nervous system is sympathetically wired
and it conducts that current to you
sitting in a movie theater
and to the woman sitting next to you and
to her friend
so that we all feel that it's happening
to us at the same time it's a very
mysterious and valuable resource of the
human
species and women i think
access it most effortlessly
we cry at sad movies we don't feel
we lose face or stature or position
doing it we see a news story that
enrages us and we
write letters through tears our hearts
pounding i've often
i used to wonder why human beings
developed these inconvenient and
embarrassing
responses this sniffling choking
wet obstruction you know the thing that
physicians and soldiers and
stock traders and journalists and
fashion models and
politicians and news commentators and
venture capitalists all must
suppress in order to work most
efficiently
i thought what possible value
function could it serve in the darwinian
scheme of you know survival of the
fittest and the strongest and the most
heavily armed
no seriously i thought why and how did
we evolve
with this weak and useless
passion intact within the deep hearts
core
and the answer as i've formulated it to
myself
is that empathy is the engine
that powers all the best in us
it is what civilizes us
it is what connects us thank you guys so
much for watching i hope you enjoyed i'd
love to know
what did you think of this video what
did you take from it that you're going
to apply
immediately somehow to your life or to
your business what was your favorite
from the 10 and how you're going to
apply it leave it on the comments below
really curious to find out also if you
think there's a 11 12
13 that you want to add to the list
leave it down in the comments i'm super
curious to see what you have to say
thank you guys again for watching i
believe in you i hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever
your one word is much love see
you